.
In this presentation, I want to focus on the techniques most used
To analyze the polynomials into their factors
Specifically, I want to focus on quadratic equations that do not
Have a coefficient of 1
For example, if you want to solve 4x ^ 2
+ 25x - 21
Everything we have focused on recently, or all quadratic equations
We have recently focused on them, containing either 1 or 1 place
This 4
Now we have this 4
So what I will teach you is a technique called
Analysis of factors by aggregation
They are more comprehensive than they may be
We have learned it before, but at the same time it is deceptively deceptive
To a certain extent, it will become old when you learn
The quadratic formula, because the quadratic formula
A little simpler
But thus things are done
I will let you know the technique
And then at the end of the presentation, I will explain to you
The reason for its success
If what we need to do here, is that we will think about
Two, a and b, so that it is a × b = 4
X-21
If a × b = 4 × -21
Which equals -84
These two numbers are the same, ie a and b, must
The total shall be 25
Let me be clear
This is 25, so their total should be 25
From here came the 4
So we go, 4 × 21
So -21
So what are these numbers?
Well, we have to look at factors-84
Again, one of them will
Be positive
The other will be negative, because
Their multiplication is a negative number
So let's think about the different factors
Which may succeed
4 and 21 seem exciting, but when you combine them
You get -17
Or if we have -4 and 21, we get positive 17
This did not work
Let's try other ingredients
1 and 84, they are very far apart when we take the difference between them
Because that's what we're going to do, then
One was negative and the other positive
They are very chopsticks
2 and 42
Again, they are apart
-2 + 42 = 40
2 + -42 = -40 - apart from each other--
3 and - let us see, 84 3 3 - 8 3 3 = 2
2 x 3 = 6
8 - 6 = 2
Download the 4
= 8 Exactly
If 3 and 28
This sounds interesting
3 and 28
And remember, one of them must be negative
If we have 3 + 28, this equals 25
Now, we have created two numbers
But it was not as simple a process
We did when this was 1 or -1
What we will do now is to break this phrase
We will break them into -
We will break it into a 28x-3x positive
We will break up this phrase
That phrase is the phrase
Of course, we have 21 here, and we have
4x ^ 2 here
Now, maybe you will say, how I chose the 28K to get here
And -3 to move here?
In fact, this does not matter
The way I thought was that 3 or 3, or 21 or
21, have the same common factors
Specifically, they share the common factor 3
28 and 4 have the same common factors
So I put 28 on the side with the 4
You will see what I mean quickly
If we compile this, the phrase becomes 4x ^ 2
+ 28x
Then this side, written in pink here, is +
-3x - 21
I have chosen them again
I've compiled -3 with 21, or -21
Because both accept division by 3
And I compiled 28 with 4, because both
Accept the division on 4
Now, in each of these groups, we analyzed
As much as possible
If both of these statements are divided by 4x
This orange expression is equal to 4x × x - and 4x ^ 2
The division is accepted at 4x and the output is x - + 28x 4 4x = 7
Now, this second phrase
Remember, we're analyzing everything
It can be analyzed into factors
Well, each of these phrases accepts division by 3 or 3
So we extract the factor-3
The phrase x + 7 becomes
Now, maybe something will appear before you
We have (x + 7) 4x + (x + 7)
X-3
If we can extract the factor x + 7
Perhaps this is not entirely clear
Perhaps you have been used to analyzing
Full-edged equation
But you can consider this to be a
Or if you have 4xa - 3a, you can
The common factor is extracted a
I can leave this signal negative
.
Let me erase this positive sign from here
Because it's -3, is not it?
+ 3 -3 draw
So what can we do here?
We have (x + 7) × 4x
We have (x + 7) x-3
Let us extract the x + 7 common factor
We get (x + 7) (4x - 3)
- This 3
We have thus analyzed our bipolar phrase
Sorry, we have analyzed the quadratic equation using aggregation
We have analyzed them into the Bilateral Frontiers
Let's solve another example of it, because
Including more
But when you can, it will be more enjoyable
So let's assume we want to analyze 6x ^ 2 + 7x + 1
In the same way
We will find a × b which equals 1 × 6, ie
Equals 6
We find a + b which equals 7
This is more direct
What are the two - well, the obvious thing is 1 and 6, right?
1 x 6 = 6
1 + 6 = 7
Our cues are a = 1
Or let me not put signs in front of them
The numbers are 1 and 6
Now, we'll break it down to 1x and 6x
But we will assemble it, if it falls on one side
Share with him the same factor
If we get 6x ^ 2 here, + -
I will put the 6x first because 6
And 6 have a common factor
And then we get 1x, do not we?
6x + 1x = 7x
Thats all about it
The total must be 7
And then we have + 1 here
Now, in each of these groups, we can analyze
As much as possible
So let's extract the 6x factor from the first set
It becomes 6x × 6x.
6x = x
6x 6 6x = 1
Hence, the second set - will
We get + here
But in this second set, we have x + 1
Or we can write 1 × (x + 1)
You can imagine that I have extracted the factor 1
Now, I have 6x × (x + 1) + 1 × (x + 1)
Well, we can extract the factor x + 1
If x = 1 is extracted, this equals x (1 + x)
(6x + 1)
I do
Distribute property in reverse
So I hope you did not find it so bad
Now, I'll explain why
The success of this magical system
The reason for his success
Let me take an example
I will use general terms
Let's assume that I have (ax + b) (cx - in fact, I am
I'm afraid to use a and b
I think this will kill you, because I am
Use a and b here
They will not be the same
So let me use completely different characters
Let's assume that I have (fx + g) (hx - will use j
Instead of i
You will learn in the future why not prefer
Use i as a variable
How much will it equal?
Well, it will be fx × hx, which is equal to fhx
Then fx × j
If + fjx
Hence, we will get g × hx
If + ghx
Then g × j
+ gj
Or if we combine the two words in the middle, we will get fh × (x
+ - combine these two terms - fj + ghx
+ gj
Now, what did you do here?
Well, remember, in all these matters when we have
The coefficient is not 1 or -1, we look for
Two numbers the sum of which is equal to this, and the sum of their multiplication is equal to
This is the result of this
Well, here we have two totals - let's assume that a
= fj
Let's assume that a = fj
That's a
And b = gh
If a + b = that
Middle Lab
a + b = that is the middle coefficient
Then what is the outcome of a × b? a × b =
fj × gh
× gh
We can rearrange these terms, we strike
A set of phrases, if they can be rewritten as f ×
h × g × j
All are equal
Well, what is the outcome of multiplying fh × gj?
This is equal to fh × gj
Well, this is equal to the first factor
Hard
If a + b = the middle coefficient
And a × b = the first coefficient x
Hard
For this reason, the analysis is considered to be aggregation
Successful, Okif we can find what
The value of a and b
Now, I'll end up doing something
Different, but so make sure we have
Well aware of the factors to be analyzed
What I want to do is to let you analyze things into their own factors
Completely
Something extra
I would like to make a presentation about him
But I guess, it might be to some extent
Clear to you
So let's assume that we have - let us take a good example here -
Suppose we have x ^ 3 + 17x ^ 2-
- 70x
You will say directly, this is not a quadratic equation
I do not know how such a thing is
It contains x ^ 3
The first thing you should realize is that each phrase
Here you can divide by x
So let us extract x as a common factor
Or better, let 's extract -
If you want -x, they become
-x × - -x ^ 3
X x = x ^ 2
17x ^ 2--x = -17x
70x--x- = positive 70
X is deleted
Now, we have something that may seem
Familiar with some thing
We have a typical quadratic equation
The coefficient is 1
We only have to find two numbers that hit 70 Khu
The total value is 17
And the numbers that will come straight into my mind
Are -10 and -7
We take the weight of their beating, which is 70
We collect them, so the result is 17
If this part will be (x - 10)
× (x - 7)
Of course, we have that x
The general idea here is to see if we have anything
It can be analyzed into factors
This leads us to the form perhaps you are aware of
I hope you found this offer useful
I want to repeat what I have made clear at the beginning
this show
I think it's a pretty trick, say, that you can
Decompose the things that contain
Parameter 1 or -1
But to a certain extent, you will find faster ways
To do this, especially with the square formula
In a short time